[Risas]
[Música]
déjeme contarles que de niño era muy
travieso aventurero desenvuelto y
recuerda una ocasión cuando tenía 4 o 5
años con mis mejores amigos de la
escuela nos encantaba jugar y salir a la
hora del recreo tanto es así que cuando
sonaba el timbre para regresar nosotros
nos quedábamos jugando y ese modesto una
serie de veces hasta con nuestra
profesora nos envió una notificación y
tomando en cuenta que hace prácticamente
30 años no existía el whatsapp y el
email se usaba un poco fue una
notificación escrita y nosotros con toda
esa valentía de niños pero con el temor
de nuestros padres cogimos esta
notificación la rompimos y la votamos en
el primer basurero que encontramos y
pasaron un par de semanas y creímos que
nos habíamos salvado hasta que un día
como eran común y normal mi madre me fue
a retirar a la escuela pero en lugar de
quedarse en la puerta de salida donde
normalmente se quedaba decidió entrar y
mientras yo la veo entre ella y yo el
medio estaba esta profesora que nos
envió la notificación y en ese momento
comienzo a sudar frío cruzo los dedos y
comienzo a pedir por favor que no se
saluden que no se saluden que no se
saluden
pero eso no fue lo peor lo peor no fue
simplemente que se saludaron sino que se
quedaron conversando y obviamente mi
madre se enteró de que faltaba clases de
que no le entrega la notificación y
ustedes se imaginarán el desenlace de
esto pero simplemente para aclarar ese
no fue el día en el que perdí mi brazo a
pesar de ser muy travieso también era y
soy un poco tímido e introvertido y creo
que mis padres lo descubrieron a muy
temprana edad por esto desde pequeño me
inscribieron a las clases de mandado y
ahora el encargado a ir a comprar el pan
y la leche los tabacos de mi madre y en
ocasiones en ir a dejar o traer alguna
cosa de alguna casa de un vecino en fin
yo era el repartidor de amazon o de
globo de la fecha
pero sin duda esto me ayudó a
desarrollar este hábito de saludar y de
comunicarme con los vecinos pero
conforme fue pasando el tiempo creo que
fui ganando un poco de vergüenza
conforme fui creciendo
recuerdo una ocasión también cuando
pasaba de la escuela a la secundaria y
el gran reto no era porque ahora íbamos
a estar rodeado de los mayores sino
porque era una transición de dejar de
saludar a nuestras amigas con la mano y
empezarlo a hacer con un beso en la
mejilla una situación un tanto incómoda
hasta acostumbrarnos y fui creciendo y
entré también en esta edad de rebeldía y
de adolescencia donde uno se despierta a
veces y ya no quiere ni siquiera saludar
o despedirse de sus padres y peor aún
y sentarse a conversar y esto se empeoró
cuando a los 15 años me diagnosticaron
un cáncer denominado osteosarcoma que es
un tumor que afecta al hueso y aparece
normalmente en los extremos anchos de
los huesos largos y en mi caso fue en el
número izquierdo motivo de esto me
sometí para envidia de muchas mujeres y
de algunos hombres a un tratamiento de
depilación más efectivo del mercado la
quimioterapia y ahora imagínense en
ustedes un huevo cocinado y pelado así
estaba yo liso y blanco y si a esto le
sumamos que meses después tuve que pasar
por una amputación de mi brazo pues el
miedo la inseguridad la vergüenza el
temor al rechazo incluso querer pasar
desapercibido aumentaron
pero en este camino tuve que
relacionarme con muchas personas
doctores técnicos auxiliares familiares
otros pacientes enfermeros y algunas
enfermeras bastante simpáticas pero me
di cuenta que a pesar de verlos
prácticamente todos los días nuestra
relación no pasó de un simple saludo es
más recuerdo que cuando los doctores
venían a hacer los chequeos de las
mañanas y tal yo simplemente me hacía el
dormido para no tener que saludar y más
aún no tener que comunicarme y conversar
con ellos algo así como ponerme
audífonos sin música simplemente para
que no me incomode
y esto a pesar de que en mi casa siempre
me decían que lo cortés no quita lo
valiente y estoy totalmente de acuerdo
no quita esa valentía pero esta valentía
conforme va pasando el tiempo y no la
vamos usando se va perdiendo
a cuántos de nosotros nos enseñaron a
saludar por educación y no para generar
comunidad no para relacionarnos y
comunicarnos para mí lo valiente
realmente es saludar y quedarte a oír la
respuesta de la persona escuchar ver y
valorar a la otra persona pero esto cada
vez es más difícil cada vez tenemos
menos tiempo y somos más individualistas
el saludo ha pasado a ser un clic o
incluso un emoticón
el internet las redes sociales y la
facilidad de movimiento nos genera una
falsa ilusión de que tenemos del mundo
en nuestras manos pero en realidad cada
vez estamos más desconectados más
desconectados a pesar de que en el mundo
existen más de 7500 millones de
habitantes y según un estudio realizado
una persona al completar 60 años en
promedio se relacionará con cerca de
5000 personas obviamente este número no
es el número de relaciones cercanas que
una persona tiene pero coincide bastante
bien con el número máximo de amistades
que se puede tener en un perfil personal
de facebook
un segundo estudio también muestra algo
algo similar dice que una persona en el
transcurso de un año en promedio se
cruzará con 5000 personas de las cuales
ni siquiera va a saludar a pesar de
poderlo hacer ni siquiera lo va a hacer
y a pesar de que el saludo también es
algo automático uno simplemente puede ir
caminando por la calle levantar la
mirada y saludar pero obviamente incluso
para mí el saludo en algún momento no
fue algo automático para mí fue un
momento de mucha incomodidad de
vergüenza e incluso de ese temor de
rechazo y esto porque yo solía usar una
chompa gruesa simplemente para pasar
desapercibida mi discapacidad de no
tener un brazo
y normalmente cuando tenía que saludar
yo ya me predisponía ya pensaba cómo iba
a ser porque normalmente yo daba la mano
o saludaba con un beso en la mejilla y
la otra persona completaba el saludo
poniendo su mano en mi hombro y como
estaba con champa su mano terminaba
hundiéndose y yo veía como se incomodaba
o como reaccionaba de cierta manera la
otra persona sin entender bien bastante
lo que pasaba pero para mí también se
generaba un momento de incomodidad y a
pesar de tener esa esas ganas de
relacionarme de generar comunidad y de
estar rodeado de personas una parte de
mi también trataba de mantenerme
escondido definitivamente el saludo es
la primera muestra de educación y de
cortesía que podemos tener pero descubrí
que el verdadero saludo ese saludo que
genera comunidad no nace a partir de
estos dos principios de valores como son
la educación y la cortesía nace a partir
de la incomodidad
no me sirve de nada saludar a decir hola
cómo estás
y preguntar incluso cómo estás cuando ni
siquiera me quiero incomodar en saber en
escuchar la respuesta
eso eso es un momento súper incómodo
y a través de esto descubrí que el
verdadero saludo también tiene dos
componentes dos componentes una es la
que no puede existir sin la otra son una
especie de yingjiang la primera es
porque el saludo te conecta te conecta
no solamente porque te sea visible a ti
sino también hace visible a la otra
persona es como abrir la puerta de tu
casa y qué fácil es cuando se trata de
un familiar uno lo recibe con los brazos
abiertos y con mucha emoción un poco
menos cuando se trata de una persona que
no nos cae tan bien y lo hacemos
simplemente por esa educación pero
cuántas veces abrimos la puerta de
nuestra casa a un desconocido y eso fue
lo que me pasó a mí en el 2017 yo me
encontraba a las afueras de un parque en
quito y estaba presto a hacer un
entrenamiento y mientras calentaba y
hacía algunos estiramientos veo a pocos
metros como otra persona me comienza a
observar y en ese momento yo me comienzo
a sentir incómodo y las ganas de salir
corriendo o de bajar la mirada y
simplemente
y rechazar ese contacto con otra persona
estaban ahí presentes pero ese día
decidí abrir la puerta de mi casa y lo
que pasó después fue que nos acercamos
nos saludamos y comenzamos a conversar y
esta persona me supo manifestar que
trabajaba para una fundación
internacional que lo que hacían dentro
de sus de sus principales trabajos era
patrocinar a deportistas oa personas con
discapacidad para que puedan hacer o
tener una experiencia de correr su
primera maratón
y ellos básicamente cubrían con todos
los gastos y todo esto que esta persona
me contaba obviamente yo entré en una
desconfianza y no lo creía para nada
pero simplemente para cortar la historia
ahí estoy yo completando mi primera
maratón 42 kilómetros en la ciudad de
nueva york en una de las carreras más
famosas que pueden existir y
definitivamente esta experiencia cambió
mi vida pero como decía hay dos
componentes conectar y también
desconectar y cuando hablo de esta
desconexión no me refiero a bajar la
mirada y distraernos con nuestro
teléfono hablo de una desconexión
interna de eliminar los prejuicios que
tenemos de los otros y los prejuicios
que a veces tenemos sobre nosotros
mismos eliminar las historias que nos
contamos de las personas cuantas veces
yo no he dicho al inicio me caías mal y
esa persona a la que le digo termina
siendo uno de mis grandes amigos o de
las personas con las que mejor te llevás
y esto simplemente sucede porque no nos
permitimos conectar desde el inicio no
abrimos la puerta de nuestra casa y un
ejemplo muy bueno de cómo generar esta
comunidad es lo que hace starbucks
el éxito de ellos para generar comunidad
es escribir tu nombre en tu vaso e
incluso según los expertos escribir mal
el nombre también es parte de la
estrategia y esto lo descubrí hace poco
porque de haberlo sabido tiempo atrás
cuantas
no me hubiese ahorrado en el hola cuando
saludaba una persona y no recordaba el
nombre oa veces también por no recordar
el nombre ni siquiera intentaba saludar
lo que me ha servido a mí también
muchísimo para generar esta comunidad y
poder saludar y generar relaciones
es disminuir la importancia de mi
individualidad saber y reconocer que soy
parte de algo más de una sociedad de una
comunidad y que comparto un espacio en
este mundo con otras personas y esto lo
logré a través del deporte obviamente al
tener que asistir a un gimnasio a un
entrenamiento a alguna práctica
deportiva y el relacionarme con otras
personas me ha ayudado a poder manejar
de mejor manera esta incomodidad pero la
primera incomodidad y la primera
relación que también tenemos que mejorar
es la relación con nosotros poderme
mirar al espejo y decir hola pepe qué
guapo estás y quedarte ahí un par de
segundos viéndote
y escuchando incluso la respuesta estoy
convencido de que es momento de que
dejemos de saludar simplemente por
educación y comencemos a hacerlo para
generar comunidad nunca se sabe lo que
se puede lograr pero más aún de todo lo
que podamos obtener lo fundamental es
todo lo que podemos dar el impacto que
podemos generar en varias vidas
simplemente con el hecho de saludar y
permitirnos estar incómodos un par de
segundos
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]